joining us from Rice University Douglas
Brinkley history professor a longtime
historian from Austin Texas joining us
on this conversation on this presidents
day good morning mr. Brinkley good
morning to you mr. Brinkley we started
our hour talking about qualities of a US
president I'm interested in hearing your
thoughts on qualities over the years and
have presidents you've studied on what
makes for people you know good qualities
that people bring to the office well
being the right person at the right time
I mean if particularly wartime
presidents um you know we tend to do
rankings here at c-span and if the top
ranked presidents often had to grapple
with war most famously Abraham Lincoln
is usually number one for guiding us
through the the crucible of the Civil
War and then Franklin D Roosevelt for
what he did getting us through the
Second World War
after that I still believe that
character matters that the president's
supposed to represent what's best in the
American public and until the truth to
the citizens that we should be demanding
that of our presidents but alas you know
somebody we've had presidents like Jimmy
Carter who have been very truthful but
we don't really rank very high and some
presidents that make things up quite
frequently FDR was would sometimes tell
one person one thing one the next he
used to say I'm a juggler I don't let my
right hand know what my left hand is
doing nevertheless he was a great
president so there really isn't one
particular standard in the old days
military leadership was crucial that's
why so many of our presidents have been
generals because you were able to test
your mettle in a leadership you know
situation I don't mean just Washington
but so many of our early presidents
straight on down most famously you know
grant Zachary Taylor William Henry
Harrison rather for Behe's on Dwight
Eisenhower you know we're generals and
so to the modern day mr. Brinkley when
it comes to you know the previous
presidents how they've shaped the office
give your assessment about this
president how he shaped the presidency
so far hard to tell I keep thinking that
he is an
Astrix president meaning since really
the day he was inaugurated there's been
a federal investigation like we've never
seen before I mean the FBI from day one
breathing down as his back about
obstruction of justice collusion with
Russia we don't know where that skin.all
and so every day you're kind of waiting
for you know something to drop and so he
hasn't really been free to in my opinion
we're still almost saying is this guy
really a real president or see just
somebody who got elected and is going to
be in and under and then endless
investigation I would think I like to
quote the poet Robert Frost that's that
the only way out is through I would
think the best thing for Donald Trump to
would be to go through the process of
the Muller investigation and get the
report out there and if he has nothing
to hide or nothing to worry about then I
think he has more of an open chance of
you know gathering more than this 35% of
the vote I mean it's very hard to be an
effective president without you know at
least 50% of the public you need half
the public behind you and Trump has
never had that and so he's always a
scene in my mind is one of the lowest
ranked presidents for first year
although no doubt his tax plan his tax
cut was a was it was big and historic I
was about to ask even in light of the
things that you listed he was still able
to get the tax cut done people will
point to putting Neal Gorsuch on the
Supreme Court even in the midst of all
that he still would have victories is
that fair to say um I think that those
are the two shining moments in his first
year that we've now just mentioned the
problem is you know he's a bull who
carries his own china shop around with
them he's clamorous he makes a lot of
noise maybe we're just too noisy society
and he's representing it but he steps
over his own message an awful lot I
think you know when we pull back we're
gonna look at this age of Twitter and I
think it's a marvelous tool for him when
he ran for president and even as
president but lately there's sort of
Twitter fatigue setting in over the
weekend Donald Trump you know
throughout five tweets and I felt a
collective who cares anymore in some way
if he starts losing that as being this
potent weapon if the tweets don't carry
the weight anymore because every single
one is inflammatory in some way then he
he I think loses even more of the power
that he's accumulated but really when
you look at a precedent the big thing is
do they get reelected their re-election
is whether the public thinks you're
doing a good job or not and so it's hard
sometimes to see how a president is
going to look in history when you're in
the middle of it but right now Donald
Trump in my mind would be very very low
he has not been able to get traction in
his first year Doug Brinkley joining us
for this first hour talking about the
Trump presidency and the president's
influence on the office if you want to
ask him questions 202 some four eight
eight thousand one for Republicans 202
semper eighty-eight thousand for
Democrats independents 202 seven four
eight eight thousand two and then if you
want to tweet your thoughts at us you
could do so at c-span WJ mr. Brinkley
when it comes to this use of Twitter
which you highlighted talk about our
past presidents communicated directly to
a people and I guess now in the age of
this president he has a means of doing
that by passing virtually other other
means of communicating well and to not
just pick on President Trump I mean our
social media environment is is very
helter-skelter I'm not sure any of us
know what's going on with it school kids
doing postings parents don't know about
it people addicted to their electrical
devices you know and so it's this a good
thing for American society that were in
this social media age in the past
presidents would use whatever they you
know media or was at its disposal I mean
I have written recently and was in
Richmond Virginia and looking at we call
Virginia the state of the mothers of
precedents eight presidents were born in
Virginia you know so you look at the the
founding fathers Georgia from Virginia
George Washington Thomas Jefferson James
Madison James Monroe in those days the
correspondence man
the writing of the missive writing of
documents writing out policy later you
know Virginia presidents of those aides
were William Henry Harrison and then
John Tyler Harrison died in office after
only a month he was trying to use the
inaugural as a new way to really
communicate a big message and and died
cause he caught pneumonia giving the
longest inaugural in American history
and then John Tyler came in to finish
his term there's an example of a
president who may was a Great War of
1812
leader you know the capturing of
Tecumseh you know the Fallen Timbers and
Tippecanoe and all of this in the
Northwest Territory but only got to be
president for a month and then you get
Zachary Taylor from Virginia and then
finally Woodrow Wilson by the age of
Wilson you've got photography you've got
a traveling press corps you have Wilson
being able to find ways to reach the
public coming up by the 1920s the
presidencies radio and then FDR uses
radio in an extraordinary new way coming
in everybody's home John F Kennedy
became really the master of the press
conference he created it Ronald Reagan
using his Hollywood background to kind
of break the the glass on TV and talk
directly to the people move move us
through his words into a realm of
patriotism so these things just keep on
changing but Twitter is so impulsive I
mean it's that very nanosecond you're
putting in what you're feeling and none
of us often want to you know we would be
angry all day if most of us are angry at
something and we cool our jets but if
you're immediately expressing your anger
we become a a country of bitterness in
in warfare and name-calling instead of
settling back for a day or two and
letting things kind of position
themselves in the proper way where I
think we're just much too incendiary
right now and Donald Trump's large
contributor to that and I suppose that
future presidents will have to engage or
at least wrestle with this idea of
direct communication to the masses via
social media
that's right and and it's a it's a Wild
West of social media I mean we have kids
I have a three kids that you know go to
school in Austin and there are no
classes telling them how to use social
media they just jump aboard and so a we
until we find ways to how how is this
working to our benefit as a society I'm
not convinced it is I'm not concerned
generation Facebook there's a great
thing
others will say of course it is that
allows everybody to kind of you know put
their whole life out on on the you know
in the public zone on incidentally
c-span itself has been a great vehicle
for public policy change covering events
all over the country not just Washington
DC I think by 1962 when Telus star went
up we could start moving images I can
sit here in Austin and talk to you in DC
that would have been seen as an utter
miracle to presidents in the nineteenth
century so it's just community
telecommunications changes at rapid
rates and it seems to me the the the
recent manifestation of Twitter will
probably seem old a decade from now but
it had a real cutting edge you know was
like a knife over the last year and a
half we're talking about the current
president's influence on this office of
the presidency we've talked about
Twitter we'll talk about other aspects
as well with Doug Brinkley of Rice
University joining us mr. Brinkley first
call for you comes from Mike he's in
Fort Wayne Indiana Democrats line you're
on with Douglas Brinkley go ahead mr.
Brinkley I always appreciate when you're
on I really do
you're fair-minded I also would like to
say I'll make this brief the deal is
people talk about the current president
and I believe that if you go back to
excuse me through kennedy-carter and
Johnson I know a lot of white
evangelicals in the south have
criticized all through those men I
believe though as a black man who grew
up in segregation that those three men
had a backbone
they wouldn't say the things that this
current president has said about
different individuals but he and that is
probably that is why he's beloved in
places like the deep south it's still we
can say what we want we can bury our
heads in the sand I want to be I want to
be really christ-like when I say this it
is still about race and there was still
a backlash over the 40 for being back to
back okay okay thank you mr. Brinkley
well first off I grew up in Perrysburg
Ohio which is along the Maumee River not
all that far from South Bend
look you named three great civil rights
precedent see if you could give high
marks to Kennedy Lyndon Johnson Jimmy
Carter for civil rights they they really
couldn't be much higher you know Kennedy
came in in 1960 running against Richard
Nixon and he did something very astute
he made a phone call to Martin Luther
King after he'd been arrested in Georgia
and that spread through the
african-american community Nixon never
made that call Kennedy was able to win
african-american vote in 1960 Eisenhower
was doing quite well with the black vote
in the 50s and Kennedy claimed it and
then he stepped up in in gave um major
televised address on civil rights back
the enrollment of james Meredith in the
Ole Miss you know was skeptical but went
along in the end with the march on
Washington of dr. King and of course
Lyndon Johnson was a civil rights
machine I mean what he was able to do
for voting rights and civil rights in 64
and 65 are the most historic pieces of
legislation since the Emancipation
Proclamation Jimmy Carter utterly
fair-minded a face of the new South you
know and Carter was elected governor of
Georgia the first thing he did was say
the time to end segregation in the south
is now and then he hung a portrait of
Martin Luther King jr. in the Georgia
State House but alas not all presidents
are civil rights warriors and I think in
the case of Donald trum
he has gone after a different voter not
african-americans obviously once you you
say that Barack Obama wasn't born in the
United States and you become the leader
of the birther movement it's very hard
to appeal to African Americans instead
he picked up the George Wallace
segregationist vote in the south like
you're mentioning the old Strom Thurmond
Dixiecrats and he kind of put together a
bit of a southern coalition that
reminded me of the the Jim Crow ages in
many ways it wasn't a new south that
donald trump was representing but
remnants of the old south hence his
defense of confederate statues and on
the mix up and rhetoric he gave which
was a stain on his presidency when
charlottesville occurred equating
neo-nazi supremacists
and bigots to the other protesters that
were there and and gave them kind of an
equal footing so I don't think Donald
Trump gets high marks on that category
of civil rights contrary he's one of our
worst he's in the same league with
somebody like Andrew Johnson who
followed in after Lincoln's
assassination became president Owens
Mills Maryland independent line Olu
hello hey hi good morning
you're on go ahead thank you I just have
two points to make
come on immigrants and I came to this
country about 10 years ago but then at
some presidency when it comes to the
immigrants it's not a good standard at
all I mean many immigrants voted for
elections became a president in 2016 but
it's not even helping the situation
right now because of the way he talks I
can't allow my daughter to watch TV
whenever she watch TV and so do natural
picture watch she faces I hate this man
the second thing is about erosion he do
not film doesn't have anything to hide
why can't he take the action of the the
the was the addition the Senate and the
lawmaker pass and take it to us
okay caller thing look caller I'll leave
it there mr. Brinkley those are both
very salient points you make Donald
Trump is is jinda up the
anti-immigration rhetoric from the
beginning of his campaign in 2016 his
symbol became build the wall he
regularly belittled Mexican and Mexican
Americans Latino community did whatever
he could to enflame them for his own
political purposes it's not going to
shine well on him in history he will say
it's all about national homeland
security but there's been a Cruelty up
to the way that he's dealt with the
immigration issue that I I find
unforgiveable it is sad that kids
sometimes don't see we don't have a
somebody who's Inouye that you could
tell your kids I hope you grow up to be
like Donald Trump I would be worried
about parents that say that Donald Trump
lies too much he conflates things he's a
bully he misuses a cyber in a way to
divide us what is there do want your
children to learn from you know that you
know there are no rules break them all
or dangle one you know dangle a foot
over the line of what's moral and
immoral and and so yes he's not a moral
leader what people that invested in
Donald Trump are ones that believe that
our country was sluggish
that we have become you know had had
done too much outsourcing that we were
doing too many factories abroad and he
was able to pick up what I call that
loose Ross Perot vote that 19% of the
public voted for Ross Perot in 1992 over
NAFTA the Ross Perot you say that the
the the sound you hear as a sucking
sound of jobs leaving America Trump went
after that vote and got it up in places
like Ohio Michigan Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin and it's an unusual election
he beat the first woman president it she
won the popular vote it was by a
miniscule amount and there's this issue
of Russian interference in our election
that are going to be talked about for
decades of Nan centuries we still have
to do something about Russia's we're
heading in here to the midterms in 2018
so Donald Trump rats represents kind of
a dark underbelly of America he's put
together a coalition of people that
don't like other Nastasia phobia that's
going on here and to me it's not gold
star stuff in history but as long as the
economy hums the stock market does well
and you see unemployment going downward
people are willing to tolerate an awful
lot and if he doesn't get us into a
major war he's not by any means toast he
could he could clearly be reelected a
second term mr. Brinkley when it comes
down to immigration compare and contrast
Donald Trump's approach to issues of it
say back to Barack Obama particularly
how he dealt with deportations well you
know Donald Trump is there's a strain of
the problem when we talk about Trump too
often we act like he's unprecedented it
is unusual that we had one president
pull on so many different strands of
American history but there's been a long
anti-immigrant tradition in the United
States I'm Catholic my mother's family
was from Slovakia there was a movement
that they did are in our country not to
allow Catholics certain Slovakian to
come in
you know John F Kennedy who we mentioned
had to combat the idea that he was
Catholic in a Protestant country that
we've millard fillmore one of our
presidents left the White House to start
a become a leader in the know-nothing
party in the whole idea that
know-nothing party was anti-catholic
anti-mormon anti-jew we have Alien and
Sedition Acts and they you know early
1800s and it repeats itself in the early
1900s
you know Woodrow Wilson has a you know
kind of ugly record when it comes to
talking about immigration during his
presidency so Trump's just part I think
of a of a tradition Barack Obama you
know and in all process all presidents
before Donald Trump in recent time
it's have been much more open hearted
about the immigration issue Barack Obama
wanted tough border security but he
wanted to give immediately the dreamers
American citizenship and let them be
part of the of America which because
they already are Donald Trump has been
using so-called daca as a wedge issue on
immigration and and of course now is
tying it to this building of a wall the
wall it's just this idiotic idea I mean
anybody goes down and travels the border
with the Rio Grande with the canyons I
mean I guess you're looking at border
fencing additional border fencing and
some patches down there but the whole
thing just became a giant metaphor of
the wall for anti-immigration and an
anti-mexican sentiment it's not a pretty
chapter in our nation's history let's go
to Elroy Memphis Tennessee Democrats
line hi yes hi I'm the elder in business
I'm also Maria administrator myself and
I just wanted to say too bad Trump
insolence he's a powerful businessman
that's what people looked at either way
that he got elected or whatever and he's
able to say it's just a poor choice of
words they got to do something trouble
sometimes I know that he can help me
you'll say oh sorry
you know say as a president because I
know that I've been ranked by the system
or I had higher Sciences putting me
under the VA and all it was authorized
by the executive branch the legislative
branch under the under the brock obama
presidency and i wondering is it
possible you know this president were
listening to african-americans and
minorities and Caucasians that they're
wrong by the system what would you think
would he do in order to take people with
those are they got violated like they're
under the under secrecy or disgrace the
speedily got punished for no reason at
all they got their freedom of speech
taken away from where the lawyers take
over God take no work all right
well we'll let it there and let our
guests respond mr. Brinkley okay
well you know I often have trouble when
we constantly say that Donald Trump is a
businessman
it kind of insults people that do
business and a kind of open handed way I
mean you don't create Trump University
as a businessman that's somebody that's
trying to pull a scam that's somebody
who's a carny a kind of hyper salesman
right of the casino bellringer to come
on in and get rich with that set I agree
with the car that's why people really
were attracted to Donald Trump his
personality
political correctness had got run amuck
I mean we were it went so far that
Donald Trump seemed to be a corrector
for that a dislike of Hillary Clinton
and there was a general feeling let's
give it a chance maybe Trump will shake
things up maybe Trump will break the
furniture in Washington and that's what
needs to be done I think the strongest
message for Trump re-election is he's on
it right now and that is can you do
infrastructure can you bring meaningful
employment back to states like Ohio and
Michigan Pennsylvania you know can you
take those clothes factory towns and get
them reopened but he speaks the language
of that the rhetoric of that but in
truth the the tax cut is one to help
billionaires now you're getting back
down to hoping there's this trickle-down
effect I do think his most powerful
moments as president not as greatest
policy achievements but these powerful
moments are when he's used Twitter to go
to deal with carrier or to deal with
Ford Motor Company and say let's get the
jobs here in the United States so and
that's where he wants to be as a it's a
kind of like economic renew renewal
agent somebody who's kind of bring jobs
back to mercury if he'd stay on that
message and and not start you know
constantly you know abusing people and
name-calling on Twitter I think he would
be higher in the polls but perhaps that
35% that he's gonna need to get them
through the Moller report once it comes
out meaning charges perhaps of
obstruction of justice if the Democrats
get Congress in 18
they may move to impeach him this is a
president that's got a lot of weight on
his shoulders right now but as appeal
for re-election is going to be I'm
bringing jobs back to places where no
nobody else cared about UI and the the
active are of the forgotten man and
woman of America mr. Brinkley when you
talk about this idea of scandal clearly
history and the presidential role has a
long history up at iran-contra for
President Reagan Monica Lewinsky with
President Clinton how does this
president and how is he handling it
differently than history tells us about
how previous presidents have handled
scandal well what's unusual it's all
been in his first year I mean the entire
first year is just been scandal after
scandal I mean you started you know
Ronald Reagan had iran-contra well into
a second term I mean Warren Harding was
on a roll um in then he died and teapot
dome kind of blew up after it's a he's
had a chance to establish some policies
in his first year Nixon's Watergate took
place in a second term he won the
biggest landslide in American history
for re-election Nixon in 1970 to beating
George McGovern Trump's unusual that
it's been from just scandal after
scandal they just never seem to stop why
part of it is he really never has been
in government there wasn't a public
record there wasn't a military record
and by the nature of the kind of work he
did in real estate in New York you're
constantly kind of hiding money off
storing money getting loans from people
and so you try to obfuscate a lot of
your past we still haven't seen his his
you know taxes that were supposed to be
released the promise did and won't do it
because it's kind of ugly when you watch
how billionaires manipulate money and
move the the the you know Nuggets around
so they don't you know and don't offer
transparency so there's a kind of taint
surrounding Donald Trump but many people
you know two-thirds of the country don't
trust him don't think he's reliable
don't see him as a businessman but CMS a
charlatan then you have a third of the
country that says this is a
president of my lifetime and one of the
best ever because he talks straight
he talks directly to me he goes over the
lame mainstream media and the pundit
tree and is connecting with my feelings
and my thoughts the problem Trump has
those diehards are 1/3 of the country
and 2/3 aren't buying the act here is
from Columbia Maryland Republican line
Linda you're on with Doug Brinkley hello
hi good morning I think your guest is
relying heavily on the polls that were
so very wrong in the first place
regarding his chance of winning the
election I don't think he's very
unbiased at all but but more to the
point I think history will show that
there was minor Russian interference on
behalf of more than one of the
candidates and that left-wing media bias
is a much bigger problem than anything
close to Russian interference and voter
fraud is disguising you know how popular
this president is so to say that he won
by a small minority or in the electoral
college only excuse me that's not
necessarily proven we need to really get
into examining our voting machines and
our systems and our local election
there's been a lot of at least anecdotal
evidence of votes being destroyed not
counted properly it's starting to come
to light but a lot of Democrats in
certain states don't want to look at
that okay well thank you well you know I
am NOT somebody who doesn't think Donald
Trump won he won the game is the
electoral boat said he clearly won he is
president and deserved to be President
the fact that Hillary Clinton got three
million more votes that him is it's - in
interesting factoid for presidential
historians but it didn't bring her into
the White House because we do have the
Electoral College and just as George W
Bush beat Al Gore I mean for Republicans
the electoral college in two big close
elections in two thousand and then 2016
have worked in their favor one of these
days it might work in a Democrats favor
I think we have to stop dissing American
democracy all the time everything's
broken we can't count votes we're a mess
all of this you know constantly casting
doubt on our system we're the greatest
country in the world we should be in our
I believe the envy of how to run free
and fair elections we have hit some
stumbling blocks we're going to hit a
few more but we should be proud of the
way that we elect people to Congress in
the Senate and state houses and
governorships all over America it has
not hurt Republicans who are controlling
everything right now
as for the caller's notion of Democratic
voter fraud I mean the Republicans on
the White House Senate in Congress that
majority of state houses and
governorships and so you know we all
need to pull together try to perfect our
voting system but at the same time not
derided in my my view because it's a
complicated and ugly world out of there
totalitarianism is rearing its head
everywhere I really want nothing I never
want to live and I don't believe the
caller does in Russia or China they're
both countries that don't respect free
speech they don't respect the First
Amendment their countries that will kill
their own people if they dare to dissent
we are so much more sophisticated and
elegant enlightened than Russia and
China and I'm proud of that fact that's
why I spend my life studying American
history and yes we're gonna have hanging
dimpled ballots and hanging chads from
time to time but we'll fix it and
democracy will move onward the trumpet
president Trump's influences on the
presidency is the topic our guest Doug
Brinkley of Rice University mr. Brinkley
a viewer off of Twitter asked you this
he wants you to comment on president
Trump's possible impact on permanently
changing Washington's incestuous culture
and paving a path for another political
outsider to be elected president oh I
don't see it that way I look at him as
ransacking our agencies an instant
Solutions you know you just can't come
in and you know cut 25% of the people
from EPA go to State Department and not
fill in passenger ships act like Career
Service people for our country are
somehow the problem they've been keeping
us running all these years our politics
might be broken but many of the people
that work in the permanent government in
the United States are some of the finest
people imaginable
as for constantly being an outsider I
think people will have a Donald Trump so
one offer I say that because the
pendulum in American history will swing
in different directions just as Barack
Obama was so cerebral some people said
professorial he went 180 the opposite
direction with Donald Trump who says I
don't read books and you know and then
that pendulum will swing backwards what
could be is that trumpism is a
realignment of the Republican Party if
Donald Trump gets a gets through the
Mahler report and gets reelected in 2020
and eight years of trumpism I would say
that is what the Republican Party is and
people like bob corker of Tennessee or
jeff flake of Arizona or even MIT Romney
if he gets into the Senate from Utah
though those are those people are more
tied to the Democratic view the
establishment view if you'd like then
then what Trump is some Saul about
that's why they kill those types of
Republicans don't have a home in that
party that's why Governor Kasich of Ohio
wouldn't even go to the Republican
convention held in Cleveland his own
state because he said Donald Trump's not
a Republican well maybe the party's
changed maybe Donald Trump is what the
Republican brand is we'll know better it
by 2020
here is Edward from Washington DC
Democrats line come on come on and
c-span how you do it very good
c-span uh I give kudos to you know the
doctor Douglas Brinkley and I agree with
him a hundred percent but let me take
you back to the history but c-span and
it so much it would be mindful of this
I'm going to take you back to the
history book and until your professor
and what you'll come in on this and I'm
going to finish this as soon as possible
can the Atlantic generals gave Hillary
Clinton never endorsed anybody president
for 200 years
except interceptor Abraham Lincoln and
and and when an American president and
also foreign generals the foreign policy
magazine endorsed civil right intended
and it does it does this but every
magazine in intestines of tourists
endorser okay I'm ashamed of this
president I'm an African American
scientist I stood a good chance of being
the scientific advisor for Hillary
Clinton administration has she got
elected she would have been one of the
best presidents discharges over here
unless this donald trump was not elected
by the popular vote he was elected but
the electoral college we had to make
sure this doesn't happen again and not
until history professor dr. douglas i
think our people need to get on the
phone and call up everybody you know in
those swing space and make sure
everybody in the swing state should vote
if they don't vote people don't realize
how powerful this electoral college is
538 electoral fellows distributed across
the nation where california has picked
up at to florida has 29 care of Stella
for state of North Carolina at 12 and so
forth okay Edward Edward let me leave
you there only because you you you did a
lot of build up there but mr. Brinkley
to this idea of the political structure
as it stands particularly with the
college I know you've addressed it but
if you wanted to add something else well
that the callers absolutely right that
he all gets back to these same swing
states and there are up for we are right
now I can almost tell you in 2020 what
will go blue for Democrats and red for
Republicans we can all paint the map it
gets down of six or seven states and
Democrats have to really bring out the
vote for example Barack Obama's numbers
for bringing out the african-american
vote have to be replicated I mean
remember Obama actually won Indiana in
North Carolina
you know Democrats can never afford to
lose Pennsylvania
like they did and Ohio is going to be an
ultimate swing state I think it's
tipping Republican right now miss you
know Hillary Clinton needed to have gone
to Wisconsin she didn't visit once it's
a mistake I think the Republicans have
to pay more attention right now to
Florida you know the number of people
that are coming moving in from Puerto
Rico of course we come in from Puerto
Rico you are an American citizen you
don't have to you know apply for
anything you move to Florida and they
are moving and they're moving in the
tens of thousands soon-to-be hundreds of
thousands of Puerto Ricans that will be
residents in Florida angry at the way
Donald Trump has not acted to help
Puerto Rico and their time of peril used
to be Cuban American votes mattered in
Florida it's going to be the Puerto
Rican American vote and if I were the
GOP I'd be very worried about Florida
because there's no path to the
presidency if they can't hold it you
also have Donald Trump doing things like
saying let's offshore driller Florida
and Governor Scott had to say don't
offshore drill this is a state on
tourism and hotels and coral reefs and
in wilderness oceanic zones
what are you telling what do you mean
we're gonna start oil drilling there so
uh Trump has been off message with the
state of Florida what's going on there
and that could cost him mightily
meanwhile the Democrats I think have to
come up with something in the so-called
Great Lakes region what are they
standing for in Ohio in Michigan and so
we'll have to see how well both parties
try to attack these issues in the coming
few years Christine from Richmond
Virginia independent line you're next
yes good morning I'm business being
president today I would expect my
president to have a higher standard of
ethics and honesty I think the level of
corruption has been terrible I am
concerned about redistricting for the
next election especially and you know I
really hope that the courts at least can
hold hold sway against this president
the Congress does not seem to be able to
thank you so much
well you know when we say on President's
Day we expect our president you know
Presidents Day was created in 1971 by
Richard Nixon not somebody we always
think of with truthfulness and ethics he
credited on this Monday on the third
Monday of every February as a kind of
washed away the idea that I used to
prefer of honoring George Washington on
his birthday now kind of all presidents
get morphed together and I think
something gets lost in that translation
look oftentimes presents or have to tell
the truth to the American people
Donald Trump you know you look at the
Washington Post ER or Politico and see
how often he has lied in his first year
in office it's mind-boggling I mean he's
the Babe Ruth of lying I mean there's no
president that could even come close
he's he's in a category unto himself on
whether people find that that's okay and
that's the new norm like if he can get
jobs back and I get some tax cuts I'm
okay with that being a symbol of what
the United States is I'm not i find it
problematic to have a president that
routinely doesn't tell the truth I'm not
talking about white lies or occasional
blooper we're talking about a kind of
systemic disrespect for reality and we
previs that a caller said I'm a
scientist I'm I all I can tell to that
caller was a scientist I'm sorry you
have a president that makes fun of and
belittle our nation scientist because I
grew up with the scientists being people
to look up to people that used empirical
data and you know people that did
incredible things that created the
technological revolution of Round Rock
in Silicon Valley and in Seattle and
people that brought us to the moon
scientists gave us our medical miracles
of today so we have longevity in our
lives and here Donald Trump routinely
disses scientists I find it disturbing
so I think you've got we need to make
sure above all the president has a
sanity to them overall and there are
times with
Trump swings pretty far off what we call
you know the the zone of normalcy he
goes off into very weird tangents that
can be disturbing mr. Brinkley talked a
little bit about the we had the
president go to Florida
particularly in reaction to the Florida
shooting this idea of the President or
this president being a comforter in
chief of sorts and how he plays it out
versus previous presidents well I mean
Barack Obama's the gold standard on the
appropriate grief counselor in chief he
did such a marvelous job of going to
places like Sandy Hook and Tucson and
beyond during his presidency Bill
Clinton I thought gave one of the
greatest speeches in American history
for a president and when he went to
Oklahoma City after the bombing there in
1996 and it's called the empty chair
speech and it was a beautifully done
healing moment Ronald Reagan with the
Challenger disaster Donald Trump watches
those moments he had one in
Charlottesville and he blew it he's had
one here in Florida now with a Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School killing of
seventeen of our fellow citizens and he
seemed ham-fisted
unsure what to do starting to blame the
FBI right out of the gate in in an
unhelpful tweet he's not only not good
as as being a grief counselor in chief I
mean he's inflamed Great Britain I mean
they have a terror attack there and he
writes nasty things about our greatest
ally
he's not even wanted in Great Britain
right now London does not want him to
visit these are problems this is
somebody who's you know that that kind
of tone death narcissism that our
president has it he's not able to try to
find the way to heal the country is
another shortcoming of Donald Trump I'm
afraid with that said look I don't
believe just cause the killer in Florida
or a make America great had it it
doesn't mean Trump somehow responsible
in a real way I mean you don't blame you
know somebody that's this
ranged and mentally crazy it's really
unfair to blame ever a president or a
rock band or us you know a commercial or
something but Trump could have done
better on all of these moments in her
country instead he goes too quickly to
do tweets that seem to be self
aggrandizing for himself and belittling
somebody else instead of doing true own
judeo-christian healing won't hear next
from Rhode Island Republican line David
you're on with Doug Brinkley thank you
thank you for seeing me David I really
almost every point use me on I want to
start with the first things I'm Rico the
people that elect Porto Rico the people
that have left were Tory go look because
you said so much crime over there and I
know that because I'm a Puerto Rican
they have had a run away from Puerto
Rico and number two you really stay and
everyone else in the country to voted
for Trump ardian killer Bulls is what
you're saying and you also must bring to
mind the people who put Barack Obama in
office were the right people who put him
into office and Barack Obama spent I can
I can name 20 things where he kept
poking his finger in the eye of the
United States burn ball with the other
guy gave the sex change what everything
that he's done the racial things he's
divided to whites the blacks so much in
his country it's not funny because all
of a sudden they were all right they
were right did bring in people that
Mexicans into this country this is not a
dumping ground for the rest of the world
the rest of the world their country
should be taking care of the wrong
people and you're not coke a collar
collar will that Douglas Brinkley
respond go ahead well you could see what
we've had a number of collar so you can
feel the civility that we're having here
on c-span and then you get a call a
caller like that just like raging like a
Tasmanian devil you know coming on the
air and just you know saying all sorts
of things that's what we're talking
about that kind of always having to be
incendiary and in putting logic and
reason
and compassion and intelligence
backburner eNOS and instead of a sense
of rage and I find that that's been the
formula that's worked for Trump and it's
brought in the supporters I'm not
suggesting that some of those supporters
aren't aren't justified in their local
needs you know I'm never who does like
outsourcing in Cayman Island bank
accounts and you know money being pulled
out of the United States to abroad so
some of the economic populist message of
Donald Trump it resonated and it should
we do need to make America great again
we do need to rebuild American cities
and communities what I'm objecting to is
the way that Trump goes about it by
trying to divide and conquer and our
caller is saying that Barack Obama did
the same tactics so now it's payback I
just never found President Obama's tone
towards fellow Americans to in a
consistent way as demeaning and
belittling is the way that Donald Trump
talks to our fellow Mexican Americans or
let you know LGBT people African
Americans women here's a president right
now that has you know a dozen women
charging him for sexual harassment going
on I mean you know his the language that
he uses about women on a regular basis
has created the whole meat to movement
here you know it's he seems to have been
unable to criticize a White House
staffer who would beat his wife and he
won't come public and and say how
horrible and heinous that is I don't
think that takes much I don't think what
people are asking much of a president to
be able to respond in that way but alas
he doesn't because he's incapable of it
because somehow he feels that means he's
having to admit he did something wrong
or amid a criticism he's a president who
simply ever cannot say I made a mistake
and all humans make mistakes and when
you find somebody in life who says they
never made one and cants fess up to it
you have a problematic
this is Steven Phoenix Arizona Democrats
line um good morning thank you for
c-span um I guess we want to share
something you guys well I agree that the
offense is unnecessary on privy you know
basically futile what the truth is is
that these rich people are telling us
bill defense bill defense but in the
meantime they're buying stock in the
airlines so that once the fence is up
they can make money off of flying
illegal aliens over the beds well you
know this is just one of the the you
know that's the guts back to look the
whole border issue was is one that needs
to be addressed we do need to have
national security and tight borders I do
feel there's agreement in Congress
between Democrats and Republicans on
that the question is is this wall our
big public works initiative is this our
TVA our Grand Coulee Dam or moonshot and
I have objected personally to the
president Trump connecting it to the
dreamers I think he's got a fight for
the wall on the merits of the wall and
in the end it's going to be a patchwork
that's already there now there'll be
some reinforcements places he needs
political cover to say I said I was
going to build a wall and I did build a
wall but most people realize that it's a
unnecessary that we simply need tighter
border security and allows people will
find ways in in the United States we're
not going to be able to live in a in a
cocoon in the 21st century from Hampton
Virginia independent line Donna good
morning good morning I have a quick
question and then a comment for your
guests are you related to David Brinkley
I'm not related to David but I you can
imagine I get asked that quite a bit and
because I wrote a biography of Walter
Cronkite I I'm afraid I accidentally
confused the matter even more but no
relation okay I was just curious because
I have never seen you before what my
comment is today is Presidents Day we
are supposed to be
honouring our president and I have
watched this c-span since it came on the
air I'm 77 years old and I have been so
really upset because you have done
nothing but bash our president since the
show started this morning and I think
that's very shameful why would a guest
like you come on on President's Day to
do that
you're obviously liberal right and our
side stays not precedents days not Kings
day it's not a day to kiss the feet of a
sitting president we're supposed to
actually be talking about past
presidents the idea was talk more about
George Washington and Abraham Lincoln
but alas the the unusualness of Donald
Trump makes him a conversation I think
everybody would agree all across the
country all the time I wish I could be
on this President's Day
feeling that the past year Donald
Trump's treated the White House with
respect that the history of the
institution demands instead it's been a
White House in turmoil
resignations constantly a president you
know under a damask Elise or you feel
something's about to drop all the time
so I haven't given up that he can't
change and do things there have been
moments of trumps first year that
happens outstanding I mean but the
overall record you get is that he
creates a echo chamber of disharmony
that turns Americans against Americans
and I'm you know I don't need to be I
don't label I'm not labeling my call or
anything I'm just simply giving you know
whether you're right or left or Democrat
or Republican or I know we have a
Democrat Republican line it's sometimes
there are people that just say the truth
say what it is obviously it's the truth
one season but you know I've written a
lot of books on US history
I edited Ronald Reagan's Diaries of
every day when Reagan wants the White
House that Nancy Reagan gave me I then
was given all of Ronald Reagan's notes I
wrote a book called the boys of point
Hakan Reagan that's three Reagan books I
did the biography of Gerald Ford
Republican I did it of Theodore
Roosevelt Republican the you know so I'm
just talking straight to you it's not a
Hillary versed Trump thing that Donald
Trump has lowered the bar on the
behavior of the presidency to an
unacceptable level you don't find it
that that way you find it charming I
guess that he's uh he's uh everyday
bashing things and criticizing our FBI
or State Department or CIA from his
first day in office he lies about the
size of his inaugural crowd bigger than
Obama when photographic evidence proves
that it isn't I know that it doesn't
seem to bother you because you liked the
brand of Donald Trump in and he does
have many followers I've simply been
suggesting he's got to get more that you
want to grow your market and it is true
he can get reelected if the Democrats
picked Bernie Sanders or somebody is
polarizing he could become a two-term
president but he's a if I were advising
Donald Trump I would find ways
particularly now with the infrastructure
to work with some Democrats and try to
lessen the partisan sniping and try to
at least for a few months and I know
it's hard in this culture a few months
to maybe do thing that we
Cove Springs Cup Florida Dana hello go
ahead yes hi um my comment is I think
they need to get over the fact that we
we did not like Hillary okay
we're tired of the Clintons I'm tired of
her lies I watched her speech I'm the
Benghazi she lied about all that I am a
military mom she lied you guys need to
stand up and what's right is right and
what's wrong is wrong and you need to
address that she's not gonna get an
indicted for nothing because of the
money and the power and you know that
and for you to set up their own
president today and speak badly about
presidents Trump is very wronged of you
that's the hatred in America right there
we might not like everything I voted for
him we might not like everything or
approve all the tweaks but you guys are
preaching hate and that needs to stop
okay call her Thank You mr. Brinkley I'm
a Christian and I don't I don't have
hate I have no hate in my heart
in fact when I die I'm going to have
nobody that I dislike because that's how
I personally am and choose my lives it's
not a matter of hatred of Donald Trump
there's a disappointment in President
Trump in his behavior because his
behavior matters because a lot of kids
listen and watch and it's supposed to be
an aspirational role being president you
want your children and say you can do
that you can be that well nobody wants
their kids swearing all the time in
public nobody wants to see Muslims
belittled wants to see African Americans
made to feel small wants to mock Mexican
Americans wants to of treat women as if
they're a meat objects and not people
with souls and consciences so you know
that's the problem I mean who doesn't
want him to heal himself but he carries
a lot of weapons of war with him in a
peacetime environment he wants to wait
cup every day and have a feud because
that's where he grew up in New York City
and in the real estate world and how one
gets things done and you intimidate and
you Bluff
so I guess because I studied Presidents
I haven't seen it before and I'm sure
you buy Coliseum and I disagree but I
would think that collar recognizes it's
something different
I would hope she would say yes of course
he's different I tended to like the past
presidents more than when I see going on
right now I don't see this as an
enhancement of the presidency I see the
presidency being smaller
I see our allies around the world
laughing at us I see the United States
no longer taking the leadership role in
the world that it needs to take I see a
white house where weekly their staffers
leaving under some controversy because
they weren't vetted properly
I see the FBI and a Justice Department
that's honing down on a president right
now because he can't come clean and talk
straight to the American people can't
release his taxes like he promised
voters he would do you know it goes on
and on but you know we'll see how it
plays out I am NOT suggesting that he
cannot be reelected I'm not suggesting
the Trump movements big but the idea
that in United States we're not allowed
on presidents day to say what you feel
is there's being misguided about a
president that reeks of a dictatorial
attitude it's like saying you have to
that's you know a worship at the feet of
Donald Trump so there's no hatred that I
have towards him what suffer but I don't
like as somebody's vested my life in the
presidency I don't like the way he has
disrespected and for the Clintons I
didn't like the way Bill Clinton did
either during the whole Lewinsky affair
and all of that it was when he pulled up
old clips on me tough on Bill Clinton I
like Robert Reagan having a suit coat on
and running the White House better so I
don't need a you know these sort of
presents that are just every day
becoming the topic of conversation is a
problematic behavior be normal and run
the country sprinkly our guest for this
first hour on this presidents day
history professor Lakes University
I'm talking about Trump president
Trump's influence on the president in
the presidency mr. Brinkley thanks for
your time this morning
thank you